nessun grande ingegno fu mai senza una
mistura di follia così scrisse seneca
nella sua tranquillità dell'anima
parliamo di follia la follia che ha
suscitato sempre e da sempre curiosità
la curiosità maggiore è proprio quella
che chiedersi come grandi opere sono
state concepite da artisti completamente
fuori di testa da artisti classificati
mentalmente malati e che hanno comunque
creato delle opere universalmente
geniali ma l'artista per esternare le
sue potenzialità deve essere
necessariamente un diverso deve essere
necessariamente un folle deve insomma
avere una patologia nella storia della
follia il termine follia ha avuto
diverse accezioni nella crescita veni
venne chiamata manina da platone da
socrate venne chiamato sia invasamento
che delirio delle muse addirittura lui
diceva sosteneva che chi era in passato
o chi aveva chi era impossessato dal
delirio delle muse creava delle opere
d'arte migliori rispetto a colui che era
nella normalità poi c'è stato ipocrite
che la chiama malattia sacra melanconia
la chiamò aristotele come condizione
poetica nella romanità venne chiamata
frenesia ma venne chiamata anche demenza
venne chiamata alienazione
nella contemporaneità pazzia è follia ma
voglio parlarvi un attimo dei luoghi a
palermo dove la follia è stata assegnato
ecco a palermo c'è vicino san giovanni
dei lebbrosi venne costruita una
struttura dove venivano accolti appunto
i lebbrosi mali successivamente intorno
al settecento vennero vennero internati
anche fisici sifilitici e vennero anche
internati i pazzi era un disordine
totale venivano lì c'era la promiscuità
uomini torna fino a quando a palermo non
arrivò il certo barone che si chiama
barone pietro pisani il quale costruire
una struttura che oggi in corso pisani è
la chiesa di san giacomo dei militari
dove portò delle grandi innovazioni dal
punto di vista terapeutico
ecco lì lui cominciò a dividere intanto
uomini e donne e fu il primo in tutta
europa a portare a rendere il malato di
mente efficiente cioè lo ha fatto
lavorare faceva ascoltare la musica s ci
passiamo ancora oggi dal corso pisani
vediamo due orologi uno a lancetta e
l'altro a meridiana quello della
normalità che dice a voi uomini un'ora
sola
insomma non mi ricordo come c'è scritto
e l'altro invece è questo e quello della
follia che che è la meridiana che dice
segnalare che ancora sono l'ombra ai
folli e la fatica ma da dove deriva la
frase la la parola manicomio mania
significa pazzia invasamento manias
significatamente privo di senno come o
puro come un ospedale di conseguenza
manicomio è ospedale dei pazzi questa è
stata la grande nuova costruzione del
barone pisani fatta a a palermo intorno
a un complesso che si chiama lavigne
cella e che poi è diventato la real casa
dei matti
ancora oggi esistente ma ovviamente non
più manicomio dal 1973 dopo la legge
basaglia nella storia della follia nella
crescita i fogli andavano c'erano
integrati nella società mentre nella
romanità un po di meno
questo invece è un quadro di genere
l'animus bosh che parla della classicità
cioè che rappresenta la classicità come
venivano considerati folli nel periodo
classico
in pratica si intitola la nave dei folli
è stato fatto nel 1494 ed è conservato
al museo del louvre di parigi e
rappresenta praticamente una nave dove
sopra ci sono una serie di personaggi un
po particolari tutti ovviamente malati
di mente in balia una nave in balia
della corrente
sopra c'è gente ci sono c'è qualche
prete c'è qualche
qualcuno che è attaccato all'albero
maestro qualcuno che ride qualcuno che
mangia insomma qualcuno che tenta di
salire sulla nave è comunque una una
secondo bosch una nave senza timoniere
una nave e trasportata dalla corrente e
che praticamente viene rifiutata da
tutti i porti ogni porto dove tenta di
attaccare di attraccare viene
assolutamente rifiutata ecco dice fuoco
la vera grande follia è quella di
pretendere di eliminare la follia i
svampa questo è stato invece uno dei
pochi diciamo rally uno dei primi anzi
che si è cominciato a a chiedere quale
legame ci fosse tra genialità e follia
ecco era stato molto colpito dalle idee
dei pazzi dai loro lavori ingegnosi da
calcoli prodigiosi continuando sulla
strada secondo cui tra i pazzi lui
sostenne che abbonderebbero i fondatori
di religioni e partiti come ad esempio
lutero savanarola e giovanna d'arco
questo è cesare lombroso e noi del
mestiere
siamo tutti pazzi alcuni sono affetti da
gaiezza altri da malinconia ma tutti
siamo più o meno toccati questo lo
diceva george byron lord byron un poeta
il lo scienziato invece disse che
l'artista è un nevrotico e colui che si
costruisce in pratica un mondo parallelo
corrispondente alle sue aspirazioni ai
suoi bisogni e di cui è perfettamente
padrone albert einstein invece disse che
sono quelli che sono così folli da
pensare di cambiare il mondo lo cambiano
davvero
questo è allora vi dico intanto da dove
deriva il termine schizofrenia che
diciamo quello che oggi viene chiamato
anche disturbo bipolare
il termine deriva da due parole greche
scherzo che significa ha diviso e fran
che significa che cervello quindi è
significamente divisa mente che è come
se per esempio due parti del cervello
non si parlassero fossero completamente
scompagnate l'una dall'altra questa è
praticamente una fotografia che parla
chiaro il rosso è la perdita della
materia grigia la materia grigia che
sarebbe qui nel caso blu nell'anello
schizofrenico e praticamente a chiazze e
due sono le cose o la parte grigia si
specializza in altro o altrimenti c'è
assoluta perdita di di memoria e io vi
volevo le gare da un registro del
hospital general de paris è un elenco di
tipi di folli allora in questo elenco
c'era scritto che c'era c'erano furiosi
fanali fanatici e frenetici lunatici
illuminati e visionari gli imbecilli
dipendenti da sostanze per esempio
l'alcol perseguitati litigiosi e
ostinati uomini amanti dei processi
cattivissimo e cavilloso satirici uomini
che passano le notti ei giorni a
importunare gli altri con le sue canzoni
e a proferire le più orribili gli
orribili bestemmia i bugiardi gli
spiriti inquieti infelici e burberi e
questo era uno dei mad questa è la
copertina della storia della follia di
fuoco che pare che fa vedere un metodo
di trattamento come sperimentazione
chirurgica addirittura facevano del dei
buchi nelle calotte craniche non so a
che
non si è mai saputo a che a che pro
forse volevano prendere una parte di
cervello per analizzarlo
ma i metodi di trattamento erano neanche
le pur che lei salassi manuali salassi
sangue con le sanguisughe l'acqua fredda
e l'acqua calda
ecco sino alla chiusura dei manicomi
praticamente c'erano invece e letti di
contenzione
le camicie di forza l'elettroshock la
lobotomia non so se vi ricordate jack
nicholson in qualcuno volò sul nido del
cuculo che alla fine finiscono i lobi
tagliati e poi le varie i vari shock e
poi l'invenzione del calmante la
clorpromazina e l'invenzione del primo
antidepressivo che era limin fra mina
finalmente dopo la chiusura dei manicomi
si capì che forse facendo le artiterapie
poteva succedere qualcosa di nettamente
migliore ma andiamo a vedere un po di di
menti squadernate questo è torquato
tasso
torquato tasso soffriva di manie
persecutive lui praticamente dopo la
gerusalemme liberata entro in manicomio
perché offese il duca d'este e dentro il
manicomio riuscì a completare la
gerusalemme conquistata
questo è un altro un'altra mente
squadernata uno che si metteva allo
specchio si chiama france mass smith e
soffriva di manie persecutive
allucinazioni visive uditive si metteva
allo specchio si faceva le smorfie e
faceva questi capolavori di di legno di
marmo in metallo e sono vero delle cose
spettacolari vengono questi qua vennero
chiamati busti fisionimia fisionomici
ecco quest'altro è friedrich sterline
poeta
che soffriva era uno schizofrenico
praticamente arrivato un certo punto
dopo varie ospedalizzazioni si è
rinchiuso in quella torre che viene
chiamata la torre di tubinga e eli
l'ultima sua poesia lui scrisse
l'inferiore che è un poema straordinario
ma l'ultima poesia l'ha intitolata la
veduta è una poesia straordinaria
le ultime poesie sele firmava non come
scart anelli è l'ultima poesia
addirittura è datata lui saletta tata 20
anni prima della sua nascita
questo è robert schumann manie
persecutive allucinazioni visive e
uditive diceva che gli angeli e gli
dettavano le composizioni questo è
frederick schizofrenico totale scrisse
tantissime trattati di filosofia
straordinari ma un giorno si andò ad
abbracciare un cavallo che era frustrato
a sangue dal cocchiere poi venne poi
arrivò a casa cominciò a pigiare i tasti
cominciava a bestemmiare
morì in in serie a rotella nel mutismo
più assoluto
e questo è van gogh vivo io ho preso
questa figura per farvi capire van gogh
dalla dalla quando stava bene fino
all'ultimo quadro dove la sua
schizofrenia con delirio persecutorio
venne fuori e netta è netto il passaggio
nel tè del pennello sulla tela
diciamo che sono delle cose normali lì
nel suo autoritratto comincia cominciano
questi ghirigori questi spirali che
arrivano fino all'ultimo quadro che si
intitola campo di grano con hi fi con i
corvi dove c'è
un sentiero che porta all infinito dove
preannunziava la sua morte sparandosi
all'inguine
questo invece lewis wayne schizofrenico
con crisi allucinatorie ecco guardate la
normalità li stava bene
guardate il gatto come si come diventa
come si espande nella tela e come
diventa quasi quasi un come si chiama
quelle cose indiana insomma ecco gli
mandava ecco bravo e questo invece il
quadro di munch lui lui praticamente
dice e dipinge quello che ha visto il
cielo pieno di sangue
e lui che getta un urlo davanti al
fiordo questo è ligabue che questa
questo è un suo ritratto ligabue non ha
mai studiato è stato sempre buttato
fuori dalle scuole era completamente un
uomo fuori dal mondo non ha avuto
genitori però nella sua assoluta
ignoranza riusciva a fare cose
straordinarie di quelle cose
straordinarie come queste ligabue alda
merini la nostra auto merini che nel suo
delirio nel suo libro delirio amoroso
racconta in poesia e in prosa
tutto ciò che ha vissuto dentro il
manicomio straordinaria anche lei è
questo
infine è ancora vivente questo e davis
david helfgott che sarebbe il pianista
quella del film shine che nella vita
normale è assolutamente fuori dal mondo
è un un ebete ma quando si mette al
pianoforte riesce a fare cose
straordinarie e allora quello che ho
elencato sono grandi artisti che hanno
concluso la loro vita o più raramente
l'anno parzialmente vissuta internati
nei manicomi
qualcuno ancora se lo continua a
chiedere ma noi non capiremo mai questo
mistero come mai uomini e donne così
psichicamente squadernati alcuni senza
aver fatto anche scuola hanno fatto
opere d'arte straordinarie l'unica cosa
che ci resta da fare è cogliere dai loro
bisbigli dalle loro grida dalle loro
logiche illogicità ciò che ci hanno
lasciato in termini di bellezza grazie
[Applauso]